in the previous lecture we went through
examples of inference involving some of
the variations of the Bayes rule one
case that we did not consider was the
case where the unknown random variable
and the observation are both continuous
in this lecture we will focus
exclusively on an important model of
this kind and because we consider only
one specific setting we will be able to
study it in considerable detail in the
model that we consider we start with
some basic independent normal random
variables some of them the theta J are
unknown to be estimated and some of them
the W I represent noise our observations
X I are linear functions of these basic
random variables in particular since
linear functions of independent normal
random variables are normal the
observations are themselves normal as
well this is probably the most commonly
used type of model in all of inference
and statistics this is because it is a
reasonable approximation in many
situations also it has a very clean
analytical structure and a very simple
solution for example it turns out that
the posterior distribution of each theta
J is itself normal and that the map and
LMS estimates coincide this is because
the peak of a normal occurs at the mean
furthermore these estimates are given by
some simple linear functions of the
observations we will go over these facts
by moving through a sequence of
progressively more complex versions we
will start with just one unknown and one
observation and then generalize and we
will illustrate the formulation and the
solution through a rather realistic
example where we estimate the trajectory
of an object from a few noisy
measurements